you want to talk for a minute but about
reddit sure reddit yeah so they came out
with a brave new policy for a brave new
world their new policies state that
communities and people that incite
violence or that promote hate based on
identity or vulnerability will be banned
okay
while the rule on hate protects such
groups it continues after a little while
it does not protect all groups or all
forms of identity for example the rule
does not protect groups of people who
are in the majority even know what to
say yeah well yeah it makes me wonder so
many things one thing is this just one
of many things that this brings up for
me is majority where assess how right
does this mean that Indians who are
writing from India are not protected by
reddit's new policy on speech because
they're not the minority when they're in
India being Indians and all how about
women among undergraduates women are now
majority among undergraduates how about
women teachers what we know what about
the changing demographics of the entire
world right what whoa what were they
thinking on what could they possibly own
planet Earth
I'm gonna bet ya that people of color
outnumber white Europeans right so who's
protected here what what what stable
context could they possibly have
imagined and isn't that exactly the
error made by so many fields before you
know this this would be in the weeds but
this is exactly the area that ecology
makes I mean this this is the idea that
like we're gonna pinpoint a moment in
time that is the moment that we are
fighting against most or trying to
recover the most one moment and have and
then write this thing which refers to
majority as if that doesn't shift
constantly notice it is is so enumerate
I mean I know everything else that it is
it's a new word of course it is no it's
beautiful it's brilliant it's the most
beautiful piece of strategy of all
because the point of that law that they
have instituted in reddit
yes is you know what we mean you know
who we're talking about which means that
the crime will be attacking people who
you know are under our protection and
attacking people that you know we don't
like hell we encourage that so the point
is look don't come at me with your
numerate garbage yeah you know what that
you know what that policy means and so
of course and of course we all do yeah
we know exactly and the problem is the
problem is there is no longer any court
where you can take this okay this the
the horizontal nature of this
revolutionary force means there is no
place that you can go and make that
argument about this is enumerate what
are they even talking about there's no
one who's gonna listen and we know this
in a sense because of the parallel
evictions that we saw yesterday on
Reddit and YouTube and medium and I'm
not sure where else but the point is
that was not an accident you know what
that was that was the same damn thing
when terrorists coordinate bombings in
different cities they are telling you
something about their power this wasn't
we got lucky this was good enough that
we could do this in two different places
at once right and so this was a
coordinated attack now what we don't
know is what preceded what
confrontations happened inside of
YouTube and inside of reddit and inside
of medium that caused this to happen in
other words who backed who against the
wall and who caved and how is it that we
in the world are now going to be left
with the aftermath
[Music]